así es muy buenas tardes para todos pues
la abstención es la gran incógnita de
estas elecciones y justamente hace unos
instantes el ministerio del interior dio
a conocer las cifras que se tienen de
participación al mediodía de este
domingo aquí en parís una participación
que desde el 25 punto 48 por ciento
estos son tres puntos por debajo de lo
que se tuvo en 2017 a esta misma hora en
la primera vuelta según también estas
cifras de lo que ha dado a conocer el
ministerio del interior- pues es sobre
todo en la región de parís en donde
menos se estaba votando en todo el país
en parís por ahora solamente el 15.4 por
ciento de las personas han votado y
también en el norte de la capital en el
departamento de sense and johnny es
donde también se está presentando
algunas de las participaciones más bajas
en todo el país esta es una de las
grandes incógnitas como les estaba
diciendo y de hecho hay varias
iniciativas ciudadanas en todo el país
de personas que no están afiliadas a
ningún partido político pero que han ido
previamente puerta a puerta a hablar con
sus vecinos a hablar con sus amigos a
hablar con las personas en la calle para
decirles que vayan a votar que es
importante pues realizar esto y
depositar su voto a iniciativas incluso
por parte de los taxistas en el sur del
país que han puesto a disposición sus
vehículos para llevar a los puestos de
votación a personas que tengan problemas
de movilidad o personas ya muy entradas
en años todo esto de manera gratuita